we're going to be working on solving
polynomial equations today big
polynomial so you can see this is not
linear this is not a quadratic it's not
even a cubic do you member what it's
called when there's a power for this is
a quartic thank you very much okay so
these guys you like what Oh gross and
huge but with the tools that we have at
our disposal we can totally manage these
now we can absolutely solve if this
thing were equal to zero which is what I
have everything on the right hand side
we have enough tools at our disposal to
solve these but what I would recommend
because I don't see that one every table
is please get out your just gonna pinch
this please get out your calculator
because going to be very handy in a
second okay so to solve something like
this we're going to need the factor
theorem now if you recall yesterday we
had a look at this idea that if you have
a polynomial like this right if you know
there's gonna be some factors because by
the way they don't always like if I gave
you some read ridiculous numbers in here
there might not necessarily be nice
factors they might be SERDES or they
might be just awkward numbers you could
never guess but we're handling ones that
are quite well behaved and quite nice
and these numbers are deliberately
crafted so we can factorize this thing
okay so we're we're going to be headed
is something like this it's a quartic so
we're gonna have four factors all along
the way here right now we learned that
if we want to find these factors we can
actually do a little bit of trial and
error to work out what this thing might
factorize into it for example if we
tried say P of two this is the
polynomial P of X right if we
substituted two into all of this if for
example a my temperature it's not but if
for example we evaluated that in our
calculator and we got zero then the
factor theorem tells us what what is a
factor of this if we can say this is
true who remembers from yesterday X
minus two very good if I see this I
would literally like what I would really
literally write on the next line after
this I would say therefore X minus two
is a factor of the original polynomial
and then I could divide through by that
I'll get a cubic and it'll be easier to
work with resin
okay so if you're trying to think about
why is this a minus sign and not a like
a plus like this is Plus why is this not
plus I want you to go back to that
statement we made from after you do a
long division you would say your
original polynomial is equal to feedback
right
your quotient and the particular way
that I stated it was to have this as our
divisor this guy in here right the
reason why I was so that if you put in a
into here like say for example 2 that's
what makes this thing disappear okay so
putting 2 into here makes this zero
which is what makes this part disappear
you just get the remainder ok so that
was the remainder theorem and this is
that particular example when the
remainder was 0 you're like cool that
means it's not just any old divisor it's
a factor okay so this is where we're
headed right now what we want to end up
with is something where you've got all
of these bits and pieces all factorize
all nice and neat now I just want you to
think about what it might actually do
because we can guess at these right I
could just try to I can try a 19 I could
try 8 but you actually can use a little
bit of logic to not just randomly guess
okay for example um let's just suppose
I'm just gonna make up a polynomial
right now if I had a polynomial like
this let's make that 2 on the end ok
now I'm not actually going to ask you to
expand this whole thing I'm just
interested in when I do expend it when
I'm finished right there's going to be
an X to the 4 term there's going to be
an X cubed term an x squared term and an
X term and there will also be a constant
term and this constant term is actually
the thing I'm interested in just have a
look at this right when this whole thing
is expanded you're gonna do x times all
of these and you're gonna do negative 1
times all these then you're gonna do x
times all of these and negative 3 times
all of this are you gonna do that it's
gonna take a long time because there's
so many factors right but I can say with
confidence that after you've done all of
that expansion that constant term this
one on the end it's going to be equal to
exactly
negative fatty now I wonder if anyone
can tell without me having expanded any
I literally have no idea what the rest
of the terms are right without me having
gone through that long process how could
I immediately know that the very last
time we negative 30 what do you say
right I just multiplied which which
thinks did I multiply all of these guys
here right I went negative 1 negative 3
negative 5 and then plus 2 is that
negative thing it is right okay good I
can still do my numbers right now the
reason I know that that's going to be
your final term is the only time you're
going to get a constant out of all of
these together is when you're
multiplying these guys right as soon as
you add in one of the exes from any of
those factors you're going to get one of
these right and so I'm going to have X's
in there Y be part of the constant so as
a consequence when you look at this
right it gives you clues immediately as
to what the the factors must have come
from so have a look right San is a 3
there there's a 3 on the end so I have a
really good guess that either 3 or
negative 3 if I put that in I'm going to
get 0 okay so here's what I want you to
you're mostly in pairs not every single
one of you but mostly I want you to get
your calculator out right now and you'll
need both of you to have a calculator
and what I want you guys to do with me
is I'd like one person in the pair to
test P of 3 and then I'd like the other
person to test negative 3 okay so what
you're going to do is you're going to
write all of this right even though you
might know that negative 3 to the power
4 is 81 right you might actually know
that you might be really good with your
arithmetic I'm actually going to ask you
to put it into your calculator like this
line here with all the substitution that
will make it easier for you to test
other numbers if it so happens that this
isn't the one that you wanted so this is
what for the negative 3 people this is
what you're going to be putting into
your calculator display
negative 3 it's a really messy 3 so that
is what you're only putting in and with
the P of 3 you're obviously gonna be
putting in positive threes rather than
negative 3s
ok I'm gonna give you a second okay so
who tested negative 3 hands up
should be half of you right hands up
okay you're still getting there alright
I'll wait for you guys to all get there
okay Justin you put your hand up right
what did you get as a value out at the
end okay that's right who actually got
there yeah yeah go ahead - Bobby - sorry
240 okay so that's a big number but
that's not that surprising because
you've got these big 245 oh yeah maybe
somebody's going around here at 2:45 do
I have more concurrence there 2-foot
okay guys I'm gonna have to rely on you
guys you had the calculator in front
here I'm like splitting that no no no I
want you to do it you're doing no I I
want you to do it right
240 245 I'm not playing you I'm waiting
for you later
setting it what oh yeah did - thank you
yes well was that that was that it was
yeah people just read my people run run
run the board that's all okay have I got
240 then yes okay fantastic
so what this tells us is if I divided
this original polynomial by D Jackson
all right there we go okay do you notice
why I'm not that actually interested
whether it's 240 or 2:45 what am i
searching for I'm searching for zero and
I'm like it is neither of those okay has
someone already tested this what did you
get you got you got zero okay now I
could go straight to one of these and
know with reasonable confidence that one
of them would give me a factor because
of this number on the end here right
this three okay so what I can say is all
from this
line if P of 3 is equal to 0 what can I
conclude X minus 3 all right very good
yeah Peron wasn't even here today knees
followed the pattern right X minus 3 is
a factor and so what I can do is I can
divide this original polynomial by X
minus 3 I will have to go to polynomial
long division at this point okay but
then I'm going to have something simpler
and then I can work on that small
problem okay can I ask you guys right
now go ahead divide this big monstrous
quarter by X minus 3 do the long
division I'm going to give you a few
minutes to do that
okay have a go and then let's see if we
get some agreement this time on the
cubic result that we get